voilà la cigarette électronique va
aggraver l'épidémie de tabac c'est ce
que nous dit cet éminent professeur de
l'université de californie
est ce une raison pour s'en priver
complètement faut-il au contraire
s'appuyer sur cette innovation pour
aider les fumeurs à sortir de la
dépendance au tabac
en d'autres termes est-ce qu'il s'agit
d'un moindre mal
et puis peut-on faire confiance aux
industriels du secteur dont on voit
combien ils ont été actifs dans la
désinformation ces dernières décennies
c'est avec toutes ces questions que nous
laisse ce film nicotine la drogue de
l'avenir et pour approfondir à présent
j'accueille amine benyamina bonjour je
vous êtes psychiatre et addictologue
président de la fédération française
d'addictologie
bonjour avoue pascal diethelm
vice-président du comité national contre
le tabagisme nous sommes également avec
michèle rivasi bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne les verts membre de la
commission spéciale sur la lutte contre
le cancer au parlement européen
et bonjour avoue sébastien beziau vice
président de l'association sovap qui
défend la cigarette électronique et leva
potage alors on est face à un débat
scientifique
un peu comme pour le coc vite d'ailleurs
il ya des arguments des deux côtés pas
mal d'incertitudes
alors est ce que ce film en présentant
la nicotine comme une drogue vise juste
alors le terme de drogue est un terme
générique un la nicotine d'un produit
dont on sait qu'il a un effet sur la
dépendance
alors il ya une confusion qui
régulièrement en fait entre la nicotine
et le tabac vous même lorsque vous avez
présenté le sujet vous avez parlé du
tabac en faisant référence à aux
collègues anglo-saxons 1 qui s'est
exprimée la nicotine a été identifié
mais c'est pas le seul constituant comme
le principal constituant dans le tabac à
l'origine des phénomènes de dépendance
paris voilà c'est pas la nicotine qui
pose problème c'est tout le reste en
gros et
on a longtemps concentré son attention
sur la nicotine et on sait évidemment
parce que depuis le temps on a mis en
place à des études et on voit une
on observe aussi les consommateurs de
tabac
il ya d'autres facteurs qui
interagissent oui c'est une drogue parce
qu'elles répondent aux critères de la
drogue et en même temps on sait que pour
la gestion de la drogue et de la
dépendance
on a mis en place ce qui est le plus
efficace concernant toutes les drogues
c'est ce qu'on appelle la politique de
réduction des risques et des dommages
alors pascal diethelm même question
est-ce que cet angle d'attaqué la
nicotine est une drogue est ce que c'est
réducteur
deuxième chose c'est que la nicotine
n'est pas quelque chose d'anodin
même si c'est un toxique à la basse et
un insecticide
oui c'est un insecticide c'est
l'insecticide que la plante de tabac
produits pour se protéger contre les
insectes et c'est un produit toxique qui
est responsable de l'addiction
c'est clair que dans la cigarette fumée
la nicotine est loin d'être le premier
produit qui provoque les maladies la
nicotine a simplement comme effet de
maintenir les personnes dans l'addiction
est donc de créer cet effet cumulatif
des autres produits toxiques qui
débouche sur des maladies mais elle est
moins en elle-même un produit toxique
certaines personnes pensent que la
nicotine produit le cancer pour
l'instant il n'y a aucune preuve que
c'est le cas alors on va pouvoir rentrer
dans les détails de la nocivité de la
nicotine en elle-même
je voudrais vous poser un peu la même
question michèle rivasi en sortant de ce
film voilà on se dit qu'il est peut-être
un peu caricatural sur sept en se
centrant sur cette question de la
nicotine et en même temps peut-être
m'est il le doit précisément sur le
noeud du problème
est ce que c'est votre avis ben écoutez
d'abord félicitations pour ce reportage
parce qu'il est très bien il explique
d'abord comment le lobby de l'industrie
du tabac est hyper organisés qui
s'aiment toujours le doute c'est pour ça
qu'il ya ce débat sur est-ce que la
nicotine très dangereuses ou pas bien
sûr que oui bien sûr que
oui elle provoque la dépendance et elle
est aggravée par tous les produits que
l'industrie du tabac mais à la fois dans
la cigarette comme normal je dirais et
puis maintenant les cigarettes
électroniques et donc on voit bien par
rapport à tous les experts qui
s'expriment toutes les études qui ont
été faites que à l'heure actuelle la
nicotine pour les dernières des
cigarettes électroniques et bien ça va
être justement la nouvelle épidémie du
tabac alors on dit m'aider à rome
on y mêler du manque de bol pour
justement diminuer l'irritabilité au
niveau des poumons
voyez bien qu'il ya toute une stratégie
pourrait pour essayer de banaliser les
nouveaux produits liés au tabac alors
sébastien beziau je voudrais vous
entendre parce que dans cette affaire
vous êtes aussi un peu l'avocat de la
défense
est-ce que ce qu'on vient de voir dans
le film vous semble exagéré il ya du
vrai qu'est-ce que voilà vous comme
défenseur de cette pratique comment est
ce que vous vous situez après un tel
film on part de loin la moi si vous
voulez j'ai arrêté de fumer il ya huit
ans avec le bape otages en essayant
complètement par hasard j'ai arrêté de
fumer immédiatement déjà essayé c'est
cet objet il ya huit ans l'industrie du
tabac était quasiment inexistante sur ce
marché moi je suis allé dans une
bouteille dans une boutique de vup
spécialisé moralisme ne m'a jamais
proposé ça donc aujourd'hui on nous
raconte dans ce film c'est un des traits
majeurs de ce film que l'industrie du
tabac a inventé la vap et leader ultra
leader monopolistique sur ce marché
c'est totalement faux l'industrie du
tabac n'a pas vu venir le rap otage les
autorités de santé n'ont pas vu venir le
vha potage les associations anti-tabac
qui sont censés veiller pour aider les
fumeurs n'ont pas vu venir le vha potage
les seuls qui ont vu venir le barbotage
ce sont les fumeurs
ces fumeurs seront partagés
l'information où se sont donné les bons
plans petit à petit certains de ces
fumeurs sont devenus commerçants sont
venus importateurs sont devenus
fabricants
aujourd'hui en france le marché du vapo
taz ses 85 80 à 85 % des gens qui sont
indépendants de l'industrie du tabac
l'industrie du tabac n'arrive pas à
prendre plus de 15 à 20% du marché
c'est ça la réalité faire est très
intéressant parce que il ya un trait
vraiment important dans cette affaire
c'est que c'était arrivé extrêmement
vite c'est à dire qu'en une décennie je
le disais ça s'est imposé dans le
paysage en quelque sorte
peut-être là-dessus pascal diethelm
voilà ce qu'on vient d'entendre
sébastien rioux peut nous dire personne
n'avait vu venir est ce que vous vous
aviez vu venir
cet usage non en fait ça a pris un peu
tout le monde par surprise
mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est que la
cigarette électronique a été inventé par
l'industrie du tabac
on a des brevets de même qui date des
années 60 on a des brevets très élaborée
dans les années 90 ça c'est pour
l'invention mais la source des
radiations électronique et l'ont gardé
en réserve exprès parce qu'ils ont dit
si on met sur le marché quelque chose de
moins nocif ça voudra dire que nos pays
nos produits sont nocifs
donc ils ont mis ça sous la cloche et
quand la cigarette électronique est
sortie ça a pris tout le monde par
surprise
certainement le monde de la lutte contre
le tabagisme
mais surtout les industriels qui ont été
débordées et pourquoi ça s'est développé
si vite parce que ça répondait pourra
probablement a besoin c'est à dire que
ça produit une certaine satisfaction et
monsieur besson a raison c'est les
fumeurs qui se sont emparés de ce
produit est le problème c'est que
monsieur beziau il ya dix ans qui fument
mais il est toujours inscrit dans son
vote slovaque otage c'est à dire que ce
qui est un peu inquiétant c'est que sa
perpétuelle l'addiction alors que
s'était présenté comme un produit qui
aidait les gens à se sortir ça serait
très intéressant et ensuite de la
nicotine
alors on va encore une fois pouvoir
rentrer dans la dans la question de la
nocivité et de la dépendance peut-être
un tout petit point d'histoire encore
amine dia mineur vous quand vous voyez
arriver cet objet nouveau comme
psychiatre et addictologue vous vous
dites c'est une chance ou c'est un
risque
alors honnêtement je dois reconnaître
que
alors je vais pas dire je faisais partie
de ceux qui au départ n'avait pas une
une position et ce qui est vrai une
position inquiéter qui était négative
vis-à-vis de ce dispositif de réduction
des risques parce que je suis psychiatre
mais je suis addictologues et j'ai été
bercé dans la réduction des risques et
beaucoup ont beaucoup de experts aient
beaucoup le reconnaissent en s'en passer
de l'un à l'autre pendant très longtemps
certains se sont opposés parce que c'est
notre réflexe un peu bernard dia et
français de dire tout ce qui n'est pas
passé par le gris de l'expérimentation
scientifique est mauvais et puis force
est de constater que les passions nous a
éduqués à la réalité de sa réputation et
vous indiquions que oui les patients
l'observation l'entourage nous a éduqués
à la réalité à la nécessité de voir
qu'il y avait quelque chose d'important
une révolution qui est en place alors
venez poser la question de l'industrie
du tabac est son rapport à la nicotine à
ce dispositif du vin potage on ne crée
pas de quelque chose de nouveau
les industriels prennent la balle au
bond et fend d'un dispositif qui existe
et qui est vertueux parce que les gens
en tirent un bénéfice
vertueux si vertueux vis-à-vis de leur
consommation on a l'exemple de sébastien
beziau mais pas que ensuite ils en font
un objet de profits ils vont ils enfants
un objet de transformation de
l'industrie du tabac va résister une
industrie de la nicotine qui est
présenté comme quelque chose de vertueux
mais au bout c'est le profit qui les
intéressent donc là il faut pas une
balle ils font leurs on le voit bien
et le modèle français est un modèle
intéressant soutenir parce que comme l'a
si bien dit sébastien 80% finalement de
l'offre et est assuré par de l'artisanat
je ne suis pas certain qu'en dans dix
quinze ans si on voit la manière qu
laquelle l'industrie du tabac se
positionne ce sera encore le cas alors
un tout petit point là dessus parce que
de l'artisanat on n'a pas bien dit c'est
quoi mettait dedans de l'artisanat je ne
sais pas d'ailleurs six mois il sauf que
je ne fume pas mais si je vais à pautex
je serai rassurée par le fait que ce
soit entre les mains d'artisans et les
professionnels de l'avap indépendants de
l'industrie du tabac en france se voir
qualifier d'artisans sauter au plafond
moi je vous invite à aller visiter leur
semble de recherche leur usine
maintenant c'est assez simple il ya 2 il
ya deux bases
son profil est une qui colle végétale
qui peuvent avoir des ratios différent
de la victime est évidemment et voilà il
ya quelque chose maintenant sur lequel
devrait entendre d'ailleurs michèle
rivasi parce que vous y faisiez allusion
il ya un instant c'est le poids des
lobbys et je vais vous entendre juste
après d'ailleurs cet extrait puisqu'on y
voit vos collègues parlementaires
américains interrogés les industriels
c'était il ya maintenant quasiment une
trentaine d'années et ça montre une des
difficultés qu'on a aujourd'hui puisque
précisément l'industrie du tabac a
longtemps menti sans vergogne sur sur
sur les sujets ça évidemment s'apprête
aujourd'hui à difficulté regarder
pendant des décennies l'industrie a fait
comme si elle ignorait que la nicotine
rend dépendants c'est par exemple le cas
dans cette audition d'attentes de 1994
sept géants du tabac devant le congrès
des états unis
de là
voilà et ce alors que des documents
approuvés depuis que la nocivité le fait
que la nicotine rendent dépendants sont
établis dès les années 50 60
on a là un lobby qui joue avec la
connaissance scientifique
face à des parlementaires michèle rivasi
une réaction à ça ça brouille évidemment
votre regard vous en tant que
parlementaire tout à l'heure on parlait
de l'argent c'est vrai que l'industrie
du tabac a été exceptionnelle pour
organiser d'une part la désinformation
d'autre part le la création la
fabrication du doute parce qu'elles
paient des experts pour qu'ils disent
que justement la nicotine ne crée pas la
dépendance que c'était pas nocif etc
mais moi quand même je voudrais revenir
sur si vous voulez la loi en mentant
députée européenne on a établi une
directive européenne en 2014
et ça c'était pour diminuer la
consommation de tabac au niveau de la
population de l'union européenne et on
s'était fixé un objectif de 2%
comment on a pu la limiter eh bien il
fallait diminuer l'attractivité en
essayant d'interdire les arômes
parce que vous voyez comment ils sont
futés l'industrie du tabac
il mettait des arômes à base de fraises
à bagdad end à sa base de chez pas quoi
pour augmenter l'attractivité et on
s'est bagarré pour diminuer la présence
du monde taule il ya un passif 1 qui
empêche un débat serein aujourd'hui sur
la cigarette électronique on va quand
même essayer de l'avoir et je voudrais
qu'on vienne vraiment là au coeur du
sujet peut-être avec vous pascal
diethelm sur la sur ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui de manière certaine sur la
cigarette électronique je le disais il
ya encore pas mal d'incertitudes mais
sur la nocivité est ce qu'on a des
études un peu précises qui nous disent
voilà la cigarette électronique peut
être nocive dans tel ou tel cas alors on
sait qu'elle peut être nocive
c'est pas un produit inoffensif par
contre tout indique qu'elle est moins
nocive
que la cigarette consumer mais en fait
le vrai enjeu
il est un petit peu différent je crois
que quand monsieur bézieux a dit que 80%
de du marché de la cigarette
électronique est contrôlé par des petits
fabricants des distributeurs qui sont
très sérieux mais qui sont une sorte de
tissu local bien implantés et qui offre
des services à leurs clients
ça c'est une situation qui ne va pas
durer
parce que on est en face d'un marché qui
est fragmenté et qui est fragile
de l'autre côté on à l'industrie du
tabac qui perd dans des parts de marché
sur la cigarette parce que la cigarette
est un dingue mais clément de klein va
vouloir mettre le grappin sur ce marché
et va utiliser sa force de frappe de
marketing et si on le voit d'ailleurs
déjà un film un ils ont déjà commencé
c'est une industrie qui fonctionne sur
la base d'un marché de masse elle va pas
se contenter de faire de la réduction de
risques pour des fumeurs qui n'arrive
pas à arrêter de fumer
elle veut cibler tout le monde y compris
les non fumeurs y compris l'union firme
heures et à commencer par les jeunes
parce que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui c'est
les futurs consommateurs de demain c'est
intéressant voit dans le film d'ailleurs
une jeune fille qui dit moi je fume
j'arrive sur un campus californien je
crois américain en tout cas et je n'ai
pas le droit de fumer donc je me mets à
vapoter parce que sa s'est autorisée
mais ça à quelqu'un qui passe de la
cigarette à allah ô va potage c'est
plutôt une bonne chose on est bien
d'accord d'ailleurs c'est bien là c'est
bien là le caractère vertueux de cette
grande trouvaille historique de duve un
potage mais la question qui a été très
bien évoquer celle les jeunes c'est
l'initiation cd stratégie de lobbying
dans les additions comprends qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs pour le cannabis
pour l'alcool qui n'est absolument pas
le fait de ce qui se passe dans les 80 %
du tissu
industriels français on le sait bien
c'est ça le grand jeu et c'est ça la
réalité dans laquelle il n'y a pas de
débat et a simplement une mettre en
place une frontière mettre en place de
stratégies pour éviter que ce qui a
permis de limiter les risques liés au
tabac ne devienne pas une stratégie
portée par l'industrie du tabac pour
pouvoir conquérir de nouveaux marchés et
se refaire en gros sur le dos de quelque
chose qui au départ était quelque chose
de vertueux qu'est la nicotine vapoter
sébastien mes yeux vous êtes d'accord
avec ça le fait que de façon il ya il
est écrit que l'industrie du tabac
voilà s'imposera le elle s'imposera si
on lui déroule un tapis rouge
et c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer avec toutes les réglementations
ont tous les projets de réglementation
plus le produit sera contraint pourra
être industrialisée sera tellement
compliqué à fabriquer qu'il n'y a que
des industriels qui pourront faire
effectivement on va offrir sur un
plateau d'argent le vha potage à
l'industrie du tabac est personnellement
c'est pas quelque chose qui me réjouit
ça réjouit absolument personne faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui les les
indépendants et même les consommateurs
parce que beaucoup de consommateurs qui
discutent entre eux c'est une communauté
refuse absolument d'utiliser les
produits de l'industrie du tabac
c'est bien pour ça qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à développer leurs parts de marché c'est
intéressant parce que ce que vous dites
c'est que c'est une pratique qui s'est
développée aussi parallèlement à celle
des réseaux sociaux et tout ça tout ça
génère une sorte de mise en réseau des
consommateurs oui tout à fait et quand
on est sur des groupes auto-support nous
on s'occupe avec sauvable d'un groupe
auto support qui s'appelle un fauve ap
sur facebook donc les gens qui veulent
arrêter de fumer et qui veulent essayer
leva potage peuvent venir sur ce groupe
pour se faire aider sur les réglages des
matériels les choix des matériels les
réglages des taux de nicotine les
liquides des informations pratiques pour
avoir des vraiment des bonnes pratiques
quand les gens débarquent avec des
produits de l'industrie du tabac tout de
suite c'est une volée de bois vert en
disant mais coûte 20 à acheter des
produits dans des boutiques de vagues
spécialisé n'achètent pas les produits
de l'industrie du tabac c'est dommage
ils sont pas forcément moins bon hein
mais c'est dommage pour continuer
nourrir avec vos euros l'industrie du
tabac
voilà donc c'est une espèce de jeu de
résistance comme ça des consommateurs
amine benyamina et michèle rivasi jours
qu'un point on voit bien je le dis à
sébastien qui connaît ça fait quelques
années qu'ils travaillent sur le sujet
qui est une évolution aussi de la entre
guillemets de l'objet des associations
on est plus sur la défense de la va
passer un vrai consensus avec des
éléments d'interrogation scientifique
c'est le principe même de la science
notamment son initiation sur les jeunes
et que est en cours des interrogations
mais à la marge sur la nicotine
on est probablement sur la génération 2
du militantisme qui est celui de près
préservé la manière avec laquelle
l'offre se fait en france notamment des
80 % et elle est votée en bourse et est
probablement de dénoncer les stratégies
de l'instru du tabac qui essaient de
conquérir ce marché est là probablement
l'objet de la lutte et une convergence
probable qui doit être fait aussi avec
les scientifiques eux aussi en a pris
michèle rivasi joyet que vous vouliez
aussi intervenir sur ce sur ce point
mais moi je voulais vous donner des
quand même des chiffres en 2014 il y
avait 7 2% du jeune qui va poté et en
2017 ils sont passés à 14 on sent donc
on voit qu'il ya une augmentation de la
consommation des cigarettes
électroniques par rapport aux jeunes
mais pourquoi je ne fais pas du tabac
tous là le problème c'est la passerelle
entre le fait de fumer la cigarette
électronique est de passer au tabac et
il ya eu des études qui ont montré que
et bien il ya toute une proportion de
jeunes qui va passer aussi à la
consommation du tabac
donc vous voyez que l'objectif on reste
pas que sur le vha potage mais c'est
vrai que c'est paradoxal à cigarette
électronique parce que c'était présenté
au début comme une substitution à la
consommation du tabac et c'est vrai
aussi
sauf que si c'est un produit de
substitution ça devrait avoir la
catégorie des dispositifs médicaux pour
qu'on sache dans le détail des
réglementations après les yang
parce qu'on sait pas vraiment les
ingrédients on sait pas les effets des
cocktails est ce que je voudrais dire à
monsieur c'est à sébastien vision c'est
qu'on sait d'après le comité sanitaire
européen le scheer que ya des problèmes
cardiovasculaires vient des problèmes
d'avc gabut du problème aux etats-unis
beaucoup aux etats-unis mais aussi en
belgique où ça même entraîné la mort de
certains jeunes qui ne faisait pas
forcément des mélanges mais où il ya eu
des effets très vieux puisque ce a
entraîné la mort des individus dont moi
j'ai reçu la fédération des vagues
hauteur au parlement européen
et ils m'ont demandé comment faire pour
que on est une meilleure image par
rapport à l'extérieur
je leur ai dit hein il faut que vous
ayez tous les ingrédients il faut qu'on
ait accès à ces données
il faut que vous fassiez des études au
niveau 2 des études cliniques par
rapport à vos produits
parce qu'on sait pas exactement aussi
les et du des produits après chauffage
donc franchement on sait que ça des
effets sanitaires
on sait pas quel niveau mais on est
capable à l'heure actuelle d'en mesurer
certains donc ça veut dire qu' il faut
faire une réglementation beaucoup plus
pris vis-à-vis des cigarettes
électroniques entendre là dessus c'est
bastien veilleux qui qui semblait
vouloir réagir à vos propos à la fois
sur ce que vous venez de dire mais aussi
sur les études que vous évoquez ce qui
qui qui qui parle de la nocivité de la
cigarette électronique côté là tout ce
que je viens d'entendre on est
complètement hors sol un il est jeune
les jeunes sont un petit peu con au lieu
de fumer ils vont vapoter donc forcément
à un moment donné ça crée plus de jeunes
qui va pas tu que de jeunes qui fument
partout dans le monde où le vapo thèse
se développe le tabagisme baisse de
manière générale et ils baissent de
façon accélérée et y compris chez les
jeunes
là je veux dire des données sont
existantes malheureusement dans le
rapport scheer donc parler malam rivasi
et c'est vraiment dommage des études
françaises ont été écartés n'ont pas été
prises en compte
pau fdt santé publique france
inserm qui vont toutes dans le même sens
c'est à dire non l'effet passerelle
n'existe pas mais après si vous voulez
pas l'entendre arrive à un moment on est
dans le domaine de la croyance à on
n'est plus dans le domaine de la pensée
alors que c'est aussi parce que on est
dans un moment où les certitudes sont
pas complètement établi et parce qu'on
manque aussi de recul parce qu'elle a
fallu sur une génération mais au regard
des données on allait donner on a les
études
si on veut pas les voir après on veut
pas les voir sur la crise de et valy et
c'est ce qui est montré dans le film -
je connais l'histoire de daniel le gamin
qui vise ce drame absolu de se faire
greffer de tout le monde la connaissait
son histoire avant d'avoir dans le film
il se trouve que dans les médias
américains il a bien expliqué qu'il a
consommé du liquide au thc qui l'a
achetée au marché noir mais qui était
frelaté à la vitamine e ça dans le film
que vous avez diffusé à aucun moment
s'est expliqué
c'est pas le problème du vha potage
c'est le problème de ce qu'il a mis
dedans et de l'année de la mauvaise
organisation de la filière alors c'est
la prohibition si vous voulez il ya la
prohibition dans certains états
américains il est pas possible dans
certains médias américains il est
possible d'acheter du thc à papoter et
il est fabriqué de façon très rigoureuse
et il pose pas de problème et dans
d'autres états le thc est encore trop
élevé donc le gamin est allé au marché
noir
et ça lui a ruiné les poumons et c'est
un drame absolu alors là dessus parce
que absolue on va michèle rivasi aura
l'occasion de vous répondre peut-être
quand même notamment sur ce qui sur
cette histoire qui est racontée dans le
film qui qui pointent la dangerosité la
nocivité de on évoque notamment ses
initiales paix avait qui signifie
pneumopathie associé au vha potage quel
est ce phénomène qu'elle et son ampleur
c'est arrivé comme un météorite sur
partout dans le monde
et puis on a pris le temps commun de
faire une vraie enquête notamment le si
dc aux états unis l'a fait et
le vin potage en tant que tel en tant
que dispositif a été blanchi c'est le
cas de le dire
et donc c'est vrai ses fins il faut
reconnaître que c'est tout ce qui est
autour qui est à l'origine de ce type
hélas deux drames que l'on voit est donc
forcément il faut c'est toujours très
compliqué concernant le rabotage parce
que ça cette cette malheureuse est
fâcheuse tendance à finalement ceux qui
ne connaissent pas le sujet de se le
voir rejeté dès lors qui a un effet
d'actualité qui apparaît de deuxième
point important parce que ça a été
évoqué juste avant votre question sur
les primo finalement expérimentateurs du
bape otage il ya à peu près 15 % de non
fumeurs qui se mettent à vos côtés mais
la grande majorité un peu moins de 100 %
vraiment la grande majorité une fois
l'expérience et la curiosité passé ne ne
maintiennent pas leur consommation
ils face à on oublie de le dire on a
notamment chez les jeunes les jeunes qui
commencent à vapoter ne la plupart la
série blanc document d'anciens fumeurs
absolument tout à fond en majorité vous
d'y ajouter quelques maisons là on parle
de la france dans des pays où
l'industrie a plus de manoeuvre de
liberté de manoeuvre pour faire du
marketing on a des situations très
différentes sur les états unis
les produits comme joule on se sont
répandues comme la poudre / parmi la
jeunesse
et parmi maintenant on a toute une
cohorte de jeunes qui aimeraient sortir
de la dépendance à la
la cigarette électronique et qui n'y
arrive pas c'est à dire que on c'est
l'équivalent des fumeurs qui aimerait
arrêter
ils veulent en sortir parce qu'ils
craignent pour leur santé parce que ça
leur coûte de l'argent parce que
finalement la conduite ou là l'addiction
à la nicotine
ça modifie le comportement de l'individu
qui est malgré lui entraîneuse dans une
sorte de consommation compulsive qui est
par exemple vapoteurs 200 fois par jour
il a besoin de sang remplir les poumons
de vapeurs contenant un insecticide
donc c'est c'est pas un comportement qui
qui est souhaitable et une grande partie
de ces gens aimeraient en sortit alors
je vous écoute depuis tout à l'heure et
je vais vous dire je mets à la place de
nos téléspectateurs et venez un peu
perdue même j'en avais un michèle rivasi
disait jeu c'est un objet paradoxal
cette cigarette électronique on est un
peu perdu parce qu'on se dit c'est
plutôt une bonne chose parce que ça
permet de sortir du labadou on parle
hélas que vous venez nous dire sens
qu'il ya plusieurs niveaux
par exemple le le tabacologue du
l'addictologue hic il est en face d'un
patient qui est désespérée et qui
aimeraient se sortir de son tabagisme
est là la cigarette électronique est une
alternative intéressante
d'un autre côté on a des gens qui
s'occupent du problème ce plan
populationnelle est-ce que sur le plan
de population créer un nouveau marché de
la nicotine dans lequel va entrer
l'industrie du tabac et s'imposer avec
ces méthodes extrêmement puissante de
marketing
est ce que c'est quelque chose de très
inquiétant tout à fait là dessus michèle
rivasi c'est un peu de vous dont on
parle là maintenant serre que comme
parlementaire européenne vous êtes là
pour établir de nouvelles règles et
ouvrir ou pas la porte aux industriels
du tabac sur 7 sur ce secteur on va
réviser la directive européenne de 2014
il ya eu un rapport fait 5-1 après par
la commission européenne qui a montré
qu' il fallait réglementer de façon
beaucoup plus importante est la
réglementation sur les cigarettes
électroniques que ça soit par rapport à
la publicité que ça soit sur la
traçabilité que ça soit sur les
ingrédients
mis dans ces cigarettes électroniques et
leurs effets toxicologiques
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que tout ce
qui est toxique au logis s'est fait par
les fabricants et ça c'est toujours le
problème voyez des lobbys alors qu'ils
soient moyenne où qu'ils soient gros
c'est quand même eux qui dispose des
données et donc ça ça va pas du tout il
faudrait vraiment des organismes
indépendants
donc on est là pour réglementer et faire
en sorte à ce que il est de moins en
moins de jeunes qui sont portés à
utiliser la cigarette électronique est
là le problème
c'est exactement ce qu'elle dit pascal
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec son
analyse le problème si vous voulez c'est
que comment on va faire avec des jeunes
après qu'ils sont habitués à utiliser la
cigarette électronique
on sait que le fait qu'ils aient la
nicotine et le rapport de la commission
a montré qu'ils avaient des fabricants
quelle jusqu'à 40 mg par line par
millilitre alors que ses vins la limite
c'est allé même jusqu'à 200 après vous
pouvez vous voyez bien qu'il ya des gens
qui vont utiliser des espaces pour aller
à l'encontre de la réglementation mais
vous avez bien entendu ce qui avait tout
à l'heure sébastien baisieux et je
voudrais vous entendent répondre là
dessus il dit
plus on complique les choses plus on
rend le pôle est procédé de fabrication
difficile plus on favorise on exclut les
industriels est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça eh bien il faut qu'ils
s'en réfère à une réglementation
s'ils sont pas capables de respecter la
réglementation ils peuvent pas fabriquer
ses produits parce qu'il ya trop de
risques sur la santé des gens moi je
regarde la santé de la population
je regarde là sans coûter des jeunes
l'objectif de l'europe c'est qu'ils
aient une génération sans papa en 2040
génération s'entendent à en 2040 et donc
ça ça touche à la fois laisse bien sûr
la cigarette est aussi la cigarette
électronique
mais cette addiction avec le nicotine et
en ce cas nicotine
ça augmente la dépendance alors
peut-être sur la difficulté de
réglementer et là-dessus amis de médias
mina plus on complique plus à favoriser
ce n'est pas simple je pense qu'il faut
garder en tête
une une philosophie très très très
simple c'est ce qu'on appelle le bel
avantage bénéfice/risque gère un moment
ou un autre
quand vous prenez n'importe quel le
traitement vous prenez un comprimé vous
avez toujours la vente 1 le bénéfice
risque donc quand on va réglementer il
faudra vraiment vais bien peser les
choses
on sait que quand même on l'a dit
d'entrée de jeu en parlant non ce débat
que l'arrivée de la cigarette
électronique a révolutionné un certain
nombre de consommateurs pour ne pas dire
une grande majorité des personnes qui
n'étaient pas du tout sensibles aux
substituts nicotiniques et au tout ce
que l'on pouvait mettre en place une
réglementation qui limite le taux de
nicotine
je le connais je suis pas je pense que
certains ont besoin de nicotine plus que
d'autres je pense qu'il faut aussi se
mettre à la place de la 2 du degré de
dépendance manger un serveur certains
ont besoin d'abord beaucoup nicotine
pour commencer à baisser pour pouvoir
sortir aussi de l'art est allé dicter
leur qui produit la ciotat bas gère
réglementé d'emblée et ne pas laisser un
peu d'espacé aux cliniciens
c'est aussi un problème c'est tout ça
qu'il faut avoir en tête donc c'est pas
simple un jeu j'en suis convaincue mais
simplement il faut faire attention
cette révolution dont on a parlé il ne
faut pas qu'elles soient dévoyées
d'abord parler l'industrie du tabac qui
perd de la vitesse et puis par la peur
aussi parce que et c'est légitime on a
peur d'avoir des jeunes qui rentrent
dans la consommation n'a ni quand il en
a peur de transformer finalement une
grâce à une épidémie de consommation
tabac par un celle de la nicotine tout
ça mérite d'être posée et probablement
il faudra le faire aussi
je pense que c'est ce qui a été fait ce
que j'ai cru comprendre aussi avec les
associations d'usagers questions courtes
réponses courtes à l'addictologue un
médicament pour vous la cigarette
électronique n'est pas ça ne l'est pas
mais ça peut devenir je pense que ça ça
pour que pour ça le soit je pense que ça
doit passer par un dispostif particulier
donc c'est comme que ceux comme tout
produit et je ne sais pas si des
associations le souhaitent
ça a essayé dit m bon je pense que une
activité économique qui base qui se base
sur le pré requis qui a pas de
réglementation
elle n'a pas d'avenir c'est une règle
d'ailleurs la réglementation elle n'est
pas faite pour embêter les industriels
elle est faite pour protéger le
consommateur est à l'heure actuelle
c'est un peu de loi de la jungle et
peut-être qu'un prescripteurs aurait
bien aimé avoir à sa disposition des
moyens de savoir ce qui va prescrire
quand il prescrit la cigarette
électronique
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas donc de la
réglementation c'est nécessaire et par
contre où monsieur beziau a raison c'est
que c'est clair que ça va favoriser
l'industrie qui va dire nous sommes les
seuls capables de produire des
cigarettes électroniques de haute
qualité qui sont vraiment dans les dans
les clous au point de vue réglementation
et ça va peut-être faire perdre des
parts de marché aux autres donc la
réglementation doit tenir compte de ce
fait une dernière question et ce sera
vraiment le mot de la fin parce que elle
est très importante on n'y est pas
encore mais les taxes certains disent il
faudrait il faudrait taxer exactement
comme le tabac michèle rivasi sûr c'est
sur ces questions là très rapidement
parce qu'on arrive à la fin de
l'émission
deux choses que je voulais vous dire
1les les entreprises moyennes pourront
s'en sortir ça joue la transparence et
la deuxième chose bien sûr que je suis
pour une taxation je vois pas pourquoi
ces produits-là serait en dehors d'une
taxation sachant qu'ils utilisent la
nicotine et que c'est pas absolument
banal et donc si les produits de tabac
sont taxés la cigarette électronique
doit l'être aussi
sébastien beziau là-dessus peut-être sur
la régulation la nécessité de réguler ce
sera le mot de la fin
écoutez leva potage aide les gens à
arrêter de fumer et donc on va taxer un
produit qui aide les gens à arrêter de
fumer
c'est totalement incohérent et millions
de personnes ont déjà arrêté de fumer 7
millions en europe pour arrêter de fumer
grâce aux avantages et on veut taxer
c'est totalement incohérent
je veux préciser aussi quand même c'est
vraiment important madame rivasi qui dit
y a pas de réglementation n'y a pas de
déclaration mais vous dites il ya une
telle idée qui a été fait il ya quatre
ans
aujourd'hui tous les liquides en france
et c'est pareil dans tous les pays
d'europe sont déposés à lens s et c'est
disponible donc il ya une réglementation
c'est ça que vous dites bien sûr qu'il y
ait une transparence toutes les recettes
sont déposées dans dire que c'est que ça
n'existe pas c'est quand même un moment
que ça répond à la réglementation
européenne
ensuite dire qu'il ya de l'insecte que
les gens rap de l'insecticide s'il vous
plaît mais arrêtez arrêtez
alors on va terminer quand même parce
que là pascal du thème c'est vous qui
aviez commencé en disant qu'il y avait
des substances et que la nicotine par
essence et est un insecticide puisque
c'est la substance que produit la plante
pour se défendre contre les insectes
évidemment c'est tout dans ce débat
c'est des choses qu'il faut nuancer pour
éviter
et pour aller vers le moindre mal il
faut le reconnaître c'est un insecticide
maintenant c'est un insecticide pris à
des doses qui sont extrêmement faibles
et c'est la dose fait le poison donc
mais au moins ça m'inquiète sur les
conséquences à long terme
une personne qui s'empilent et poum 200
fois par jour de vapeurs contenant la
nicotine plus toutes sortes d'autres
substances
pendant 20 30 ans et pour ça on n'a
absolument pas le recul nécessaire pour
savoir quelles seront les conséquences
et on n'aimerait pas que dans trente ans
on se disent mince on a une deuxième
épidémie on avait l'épidémie de la
cigarette et maintenant on à l'épidémie
de la cigarette électronique ça prouve
une chose en tout cas d'abord c'était
passionnant mais ça prouve que il faudra
refaire cette émission assez
régulièrement parce que naturellement
voilà l'état des connaissances
scientifiques aura évolué dans quelques
années merci infiniment nous avoir
éclairé sur ce débat qui est très
complexe on l'a vu merci à chacun et
chacune d'entre vous de nous avoir suivi
et à très bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]